against them to see such an attention to
your summit and such an expectation of
news good news
security is something that is obviously
lacking right now and our cooperation
here in NATO of all Partners is
something that will definitely fill the
security deficit Ukraine is already and
will always be a contributor to our
common security Securities our key
objective for the NATO Summit for all
the meetings and for all of our
Communications first I would like to
welcome the extension of the Mandate of
Mr Secretary General
for another year and I thank you Jens
for your support I highly appreciate
this thank you second we have now
discussed in detail the situation
regarding the confrontation with Russia
what we're doing for the sake of peace
and security and what we can still do to
give more protection to our people
that is primarily concerns the security
defense assistance from our partners and
I'd like to say that we have some
positive news on the new packages of
Defense support coming from our partners
and here in the summit we already have a
number of meetings we have a number of
arrangements and I'm grateful to all
those leaders who offered these packages
of support to us thirdly we discussed
the expectations of NATO Summit now it's
important that a Ukraine will not need a
membership action plan on its way to
Nato and
I would like to extend words of
gratitude to you Jens for this important
steps I know how many conversations or
Arrangements were to be made for such an
event we have taken a long path in
interoperability with NATO and our
soldiers have a good Expo expertise in
cooperation with NATO and they have
proven they can well use the weapons and
they prove that the global democracy is
for stronger than the terrorist attacks
and terrorist pranks and even during the
full-scale war against Russia Ukraine
continues to conduct reform and in the
process of our EU integration we have
clearly outlined what do we need to do
and we're doing that therefore we highly
appreciate the recognition that Ukraine
will not need a membership action plan
on its way to Nato I would like to have
a success on this Summit for everyone
for our soldiers for our citizens for
our children for everyone and
particularly the security guarantees
there is so important for the people the
security guarantees for Ukraine on our
way to Nato not in state of NATO but as
security guarantees on our way to
integration
and uh today there's guarantees uh could
be confirmed by the G7 countries and if
this will happen and we'll be working on
that this will surely become a very
important
and specific success we can state that
the results of the summit are good but
should we receive an invitation day
would be the the optimum
and I would like to extend words of
gratitude to Lithuania not just for this
Summit and for the energy
that this Summit is full of we can see
all those flags on the street this is
the human relations not an artificial
one I'd like to extend words of
gratitude for this
this is exactly the support for us and
the energy
for us as we're not in NATO yeah but
this is already the reality this is our
prediction this is the great support
coming from the societies of around the
world and I thank you for this I think
this is the most important this is the
phase in Ukraine as a future fully
fledged member to the alliance and a
face to Ukraine as a guarantor over
security
and a face in Ukraine
as a Victorious party and this war for
the freedom for the values of Ukraine
once again thank you glory to Ukraine